the pandemic is also more widespread
than it has been at any time before with
hospitalizations on the rise
in nearly all 50 states carter evans
visited one small hospital in rupert
idaho
which is in a desperate situation
with more people testing positive for
the coronavirus every day
rural hospitals are struggling to keep
up we got a look inside minidoka
memorial in
southern idaho where they have 17 beds
and room for only three covid patients
this is what we call the empty room
nurse melissa bedkey has already been
helping transfer the most
critically ill to other larger hospitals
for months
how soon do you think you'll have a cova
patient back in here we've only had a
room open for like 12 hours at a time
as many of those hospitals near capacity
she worries about what's coming
have you ever had to make a decision who
gets care and who doesn't
never we've never we've trained things
like that and training's so different
than when you actually get the real live
body in here to figure out what to do
and we haven't this is one of the
hospitals makeshift
covert rooms you can see they've
separated it out here with plastic a
window so nurses can see through
they've also reversed the air
conditioning system so the air is sucked
in
and no virus can come out
this 85 year old man is infected and has
been
hospitalized here for four days is he
getting better
he's pretty weak and that's one of the
common symptoms for a lot of people
kelsey phillips and nurses at small
hospitals around the country
are working non-stop very tiring and
exhausting you're breathing the same air
all day long
and for them concern about the virus
doesn't end when their shift is over
you got kids you worry about bringing
this home to them sure i do
yes i have a son who has asthma my
husband and i both work here so when we
get home we are
stripping in the garage throw our
clothes into the washer on the way
through the kids have to stay in their
room
it's changed the way we have to do
things at home not just at work
now if the bigger hospitals reach
capacity one nurse told me they'd turn
the entire medical floor into a coveted
ward
that means they'd have to put other
patients into surgical rooms
and when they fill up the hallways gail
they hope it doesn't come to that
well we all hope that thank you very
much carter